hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be freaking out over the absolutely
insane and completely game-changing new
chapter of the boku no hero manga
shigaraki is back in action for all we
know he could already be in his
perfected final form and he just
challenged the world's strongest woman
stars and stripes to an aerial showdown
this fight could determine the outcome
of the entire hero versus villain
conflict in japan and by the way it
looks like this conflict just went
global we may be hitting world war
proportions at this point so let's get
into it if you enjoyed the pocono hero
content on this channel and you want us
to keep it going please leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it really helps with the youtube
algorithm and of course if you're new to
the channel or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet it would actually
be a huge help to us if you would make
this video the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications people often
complain that they can't see our videos
in the recommended and that's just how
youtube is to make sure that you will
see our future videos you have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting that
option that says all you can also hit me
up on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned we start off with an epic
cover featuring freedom waifu herself
stars and stripes her introduction sent
fans into full simp mode last week but
not me not animak from anime uproar do i
love a woman who can kick my ass yes yes
i do is stars and stripes the ultimate
chadli mad lass yes yes she is but is
that going to distract me from the
intricate philosophical undertones of
the story itself no never and for all of
you guys commenting down in the comments
about how i simp for every attractive
female character who is introduced in
the story how
dare you i mean do i simp for stars and
stripes miruko lady nagant yes yes i do
do i also simp for mount lady ryukyu
ooabami pixie bob yes wait where was i
going with this anyway the chapter
begins with all for one sitting on his
villain throne surrounded by his high
end nomu he says that the stakes are now
higher than ever before and as this
chapter progresses we see just how right
he was all for one appears to be hiding
in some cave in the middle of nowhere
and he tells spinner that because all
those prison escapees have been keeping
the police busy the villains managed to
win this little game of hide and seek by
this all for one is referring to the
game of keeping shigaraki hidden away
from the heroes long enough for his
procedure to be completed and for his
body to be perfected spinner wonders why
they didn't just leave japan since that
would ensure that they didn't get caught
but all for one explains that his next
goal is to get his hands on one for all
he can't do that if he leaves japan so
he has to stay here and wait for the
right moment to strike all for one also
says that he has already laid out plans
that span multiple lifetimes so he
intends to stay multiple steps ahead of
the heroes for generations to come and i
am sure that all of all for one's plans
will totally turn out as he expects them
to because that is definitely what
happens with the master plans of
villains in shonen manga all for one
then takes the conflict in the story to
a global level he explains that he has
villain friends all over the world due
to all might's actions over the course
of many years organized crime in japan
was almost completely wiped out but this
was not the case in other countries so
that implies that all for one has some
extremely powerful and well-organized
villain allies overseas we already know
that the heroes in japan are going to
get help from the heroes from other
countries but it seems that the villains
may also be getting help from
overpowered international villains and
that could create a legitimately global
conflict within the mha world we might
even see some sort of heroes versus
villains world war before the series
comes to an end and that would
definitely be a fitting climactic ending
to this action-packed manga all for one
also says something extremely
interesting and extremely ominous he
says that stars and stripes aka america
chan aka freedom waifu is both the
greatest hurdle and the greatest
opportunity for the villains she is the
world's strongest woman hailing from the
home of the heroes the land of the free
the birthplace of chuck norris and
because she is known to be virtuous and
incorruptable and because she is
extremely strong her potential
involvement in this conflict could be a
massive challenge for the villains but
at the same time stars and stripes
coming to japan means that all for one
has the chance to potentially steal her
quirk and all for one implies that her
quirk is so strong that if he managed to
steal it the conflict would be all but
over unfortunately this chapter doesn't
yet reveal what exactly her quirk is but
it's obvious that the quirk is
incredibly powerful and as the chapter
unfolds it becomes clear that we are
about to see stars and stripes actually
using her quirk very very soon we then
spend some time on spinner and his role
in the conflict all for one reminds
spinner that he used to be discriminated
against because of his physical
appearance but now that he's joined the
league he has become a hero of sorts to
those who were discriminated like he was
we then see that there are still some
executives of the paranormal liberation
front out there skeptic is still out
there and of course there are a lot of
disgruntled people who sympathize with
the plf cause since the league of
villains were recognized as leaders by
redestro and since they are still free
and active they can be the ones who
revive the plf cause and recruit even
more members to the movement ultimately
skeptic hopes that they can all work
together to support perfect chicagy in
his mission to destroy the future and
remake it in his own image it's
interesting that direct attention was
given to spinner in this chapter given
what we saw stain do in the last few
chapters don't forget that spinner
idolizes stain stain is the whole reason
why spinner decided to join the league
of villains when spinner realizes that
stain is now working with the heroes his
loyalties may be tested i think that
this is why all for one wanted to remind
spinner about his past discrimination in
this specific moment all for one wants
to ensure that spinner will remain loyal
to the league even when he learns about
stains actions i'm not like a massive
fan of spinner or anything he's just
like an okay side character in my
opinion but i am definitely curious to
see how he will react when he comes face
to face with stain in the future and
when they find themselves on the
opposite sides of this conflict we then
jump to hawks and genus cruising around
in genus batmobile and talking about
freedom waifu she is expected to enter
japanese airspace shortly and the top
pro heroes are rushing out to meet her
once she arrives it is clear that both
hawks and genius think very highly of
america chan and she's definitely being
built up as one of the most impressive
heroes on the planet so i can't wait to
see her in action and speaking of seeing
her in action hawks and genius's casual
conversation is suddenly interrupted by
tsukauchi who informs the two of them
and endeavour that the japanese
government has detected something
strange in the airspace near the
location where stars and stripes is
supposed to land we then see freedom
waifu stealth bombers floating above the
clouds but coming out to meet them
before they can reach japan is none
other than freaking shigeraki himself
standing on the back of a flying nomu
shigaraki appears to be fully conscious
and ready to do battle as amerika chan
asks him whether he is the villain known
as all for one shigaraki says who am i
indeed and that is how this insane
chapter ends whoa what just happened
here we just learned in the previous
chapter that shigaraki's procedure would
be complete in only three days which was
a massive shock on its own but then in
the very next chapter we see shigaraki
back in business and facing off against
everyone's favorite new buff waifu stars
and stripes have three days already
passed or is shigaraki risking going out
in his imperfect form because he
couldn't allow stars and stripes to link
up with the other heroes in japan either
way this is such a high-stakes showdown
if stars and stripes wins here all for
one's entire master plan would basically
collapse but if stars and stripes loses
and if offer one succeeds in stealing
her quirk like he is planning to then
the heroes are essentially screwed big
time also is this even the shigaraki we
know is it all for one completely
controlling his body or is this
something in between a mixture of
shigerakis and all for one's
consciousnesses working together can
shigaraki in this current form actually
take stars and stripes down also what is
america chan's quirk her quirk is
definitely extremely strong because all
for one desperately wants to steal it
and i'm guessing that it's probably
going to be heavily inspired by the
abilities of superman but that is just
my personal speculation this was such an
exciting chapter and i can't wait to see
what happens next i mean just a few
chapters ago we at giro talking about
bringing the band back to make the
people at the shelter feel better and
now we are right back to shigaraki
facing off against the world's strongest
woman in what could be a make or break
fight the boku no hero end game is about
to begin and things will only get
crazier from here on out definitely let
me know what you guys thought of this
chapter in the comments and what do you
think freedom waifu's quirk is going to
be i always love hearing from you guys
especially after such an intense and
game-changing chapter so don't forget to
leave your feedback if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more boku no
hero videos right here on the channel in
the future please leave a like and
comment it only takes a second but it
helps a lot and if you're new to anime
out pro or maybe watch our videos but
you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror i
want to give a quick thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible special thank you
to alpha sigma this man is an absolute
mad lad and a disciple of lord twigo
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clans including ingrata
pate heffa al-jatal hinokamian water the
toasted chi the spike corey mcgowan
kaido might be a gyarados dylan isidor
spidey life tinel tungsten tarkis big
buddhist cody hebert monkey d quilly and
jeremy cummings finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired raven angel crews rathu indiora
very gucci alicia actor bonnie parks joy
and garcia ted no ted and fat boy games
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you